MAX SALTONSTALL: [INAUDIBLE].
LORIN PRICE: [INAUDIBLE]
MAX SALTONSTALL: Wait a second.
What is your role, again?
LORIN PRICE: I'm a wizard.
See, I have a wand.
MAX SALTONSTALL: I thought I
was the wizard in this party.
Can we clarify our roles
a little bit before we get
any deeper into this dungeon?
LORIN PRICE: You know,
keeping track of custom roles
on GCP using Deployment Manager
is so much easier than this.
MAX SALTONSTALL: Great,
let's do that instead.
LORIN PRICE: To build
this yourself, first,
you must make sure that
the Deployment Manager
API and the Identity and
Access Management API
are enabled in your API library.
If they aren't, enable both,
and give it a few minutes
to propagate before
trying this out.
Next, if you want to follow
along with the exact demo,
you can clone the
contents from the GitHub
repo linked in the description.
I want to start by
showing you the roles that
already exist in my project.
It's pretty minimal,
and most are predefined.
When we're finished, we'll have
a new customer all listed here.
Let's move on to explore the
contents of this GitHub repo
I've cloned in the Cloud Shell.
You'll see three
different types of files
each existing at the project
and organization levels.
Let's dig into the project level
for the purposes of this demo.
The yaml file is
called a configuration.
Configurations describe
resources and their properties,
such as the name,
description, and permissions.
This is what will
hold the customer
all permissions for the demo.
The second file
type is the schema.
These files specify
all possible properties
for a given resource and
their default values.
Finally, there are
templates, which
can be Jinja or Python files.
Templates enhance
configuration files
by allowing you to break
it down into reusable parts
for the Deployment Manager.
So let's go ahead and
create a deployment.
I'll use the yaml config file
to create a custom role that
gives me permissions
to manage all
of the descriptions
of the spells
that I know in
Google Cloud Storage.
We'll give it a
minute to finish,
and if all goes
according to plan,
we should see the completed
state with no errors.
I can now go into
the IAM console,
jumping down to roles,
and sort by custom.
If I click into the
role that was created,
I can see the permissions
that it was given
in the yaml configuration file.
MAX SALTONSTALL:
That all seems great,
but what if I level up and want
to make changes to the role
that I've deployed?
LORIN PRICE: Funny that you ask.
Let's jump back into
our yaml configuration.
I'm going to change our stage
from EAP to alpha and add
a new permission, so now
I can upload objects.
Instead of creating
another new deployment,
I'm going to update my
existing deployment referencing
the same configuration file.
Back in the console, we can
refresh the IAM role page,
and see right away
that the role stage has
been upgraded to alpha.
And our extra
permission was added.
MAX SALTONSTALL: That really
makes this process super
easy for managing custom roles.
I finally understand
who can do what job.
LORIN PRICE: It really does.
And the great thing
is if a person
is assigned a custom
role, changes to the role
take effect as soon as
the role is updated.
MAX SALTONSTALL: If
you enjoyed this video,
subscribe below from our
Google Cloud content.
And comment to
tell us what you'd
like to learn about
in our next episode.
LORIN PRICE: Thanks
for watching.